welcome back we're monitoring the
situation in lower Manhattan where eight
people died earlier today after a man
deliberately drove a rental truck down a
crowded bike path in an act of pure
terrorism future historians will no
doubt write about radical Islamic
terrorism as a major issue of our time
and I hope we will leave lessons on how
to defeat jihad for the future
but maybe we won't considering how
history has been treated recently in
America last night when I sat down with
White House chief of staff John Kelly we
discussed the recent efforts primarily
from the left to tear down and wipe away
monuments and relics of some of the most
important leaders in American history
here's what general Kelly had to say I
think it's just very very dangerous and
it shows you what how much of a lack of
appreciation of history and what history
is I would tell you that robert e lee
was an honorable man he was a man that
gave up gave up his country to fight for
his state which in 150 years ago was
more important than country it was
always loyalty to state first back in
those days now it's different today but
the the lack of an ability to compromise
led to the Civil War and men and women
of good faith on both sides made their
stand of course the very suggestion that
our history be appreciated warts and all
led to what has become a common media
practice in these times mass hysteria
this was not a close call America
mattered then and it matters now history
is not history when it comes to the
Civil War these monuments were put up
during reconstruction to continue to
stick it to freed black people and to
let him know that there would be a new
Jim Crow the language Kelly used is
straight out of sort of mid 20th century
text books you know it's the it's the
myth of the lost cause which whether the
Confederacy is noble leaders like robert
e lee being motivated not over slavery
but over love of state first if mr.
Gregory mr. Avalon
to do the smallest fittest research they
would quickly discover that even folks
like renowned civil war historian Shelby
Foote and you know that rabid alt writer
expressed Kelly's very sentiment joining
us now for reaction to historians Craig
Shirley a presidential historian in
Ronald Reagan biographer the author of
the new book citizen Newt and Jane
Hampton cook the author of nine books
about US presidents in American history
great to see both of you Jane let's
start with you he got hammered Kelley
for the comments he made yesterday about
robert e lee he did I I was reading the
criticism and I thought this is really
exaggerated I mean maybe Kelley general
Kelly's thoughts were incomplete he
could have mentioned slavery he could
have explained more about that is
slavery that's something we don't know
about at this right but but he's not a
historian and I think he's got such a
mellow calm tone to him you listening to
him talk I just didn't get the sense
that he was being disrespectful or out
of sync with history Craig
John F Kennedy talked about the gallant
failure of robert e lee in in how he
moved forward with toward reconstruction
with the bravery of his troops FDR if
one of the finest christian gentlemen
one of the finest soldiers america had
ever seen Johnny D R and John F Kennedy
John McCain right where the song thank
you robert e lee because we laid down
his arms at Appomattox and widely is
indeed great is because of what he did
after the Civil War because Jefferson
Davis the president of South wanted to
break up the Confederate Army for
militias and guerrilla units and keep
the war going and they would have to
those southern boys were born with guns
coming out of the womb is that they
could live off the land for many many
years and they could keep the war going
for a number of years we broke with
Jefferson Davis's said no we must rejoin
the Union lay down your arms go back to
your farms anything a Jane of the
American story
it's it's it we hope it's an unending
story it just goes on and on and on like
in all of our lives we have failures we
have triumphs we have successes we have
we have virtues and sins and yet we want
to look at each monument or relic
through the eyes of the politically
correct idea of the time
obviously everyone knows that slavery is
evil but the idea that because someone
happened to be born in the south and how
many people maybe do you historians know
how many southerners didn't side with
the South not many right not not many at
least during the war it's a worn out
slave owners right most of them are not
slave owners but isn't it important now
that we have a historical understanding
that we can all we can gravitate toward
we have to agree on everything but there
are certain things like the anthem and
in our founding that we can say god
these were truly great men made great
sacrificial concern for the future of
the country well and it's looking at
individuals with optimism and hope and
seeing the good I mean I write books
about history because of patriotism to
inspire the good and the hopeful in our
country King George the third after the
Revolutionary War our enemy during the
revolution said he believed that
Republican governments were dependent on
an ardent love of country
he even recognized that patriotism was a
key to a republican government
continuing and he was our enemy during
the revolution de Tocqueville yeah
Lafayette I mean they came to this this
place this new place there's something
incredible going on they almost love the
country more than people who are just
being born and bred we have these
terrorist attacks mass migration of
people into the United States from
countries are very different doesn't
when they can't come here and be
successful right but boy when we don't
even teach our own citizens the goodness
that is America what are we gonna do
what does this mean for the people
coming in from totally different
cultures well obviously we're worried
about the future we're not teaching the
past how can we expect to teach the
present into the future is that who the
enemy is why he's here why he shouldn't
be here what is going on in this country
what is the battle at stake is that if
we don't understand the meaning of the
American Revolution how a hundred years
from now are we gonna expect students to
understand the meaning of the war on
terror and Craig but remember the
Reagan's farewell address because right
knows every speech Reagan farewell
address full spoke about the teaching of
history about how important it was
that's right exactly we've got to know
you know why we flew those missions we
know what we did on d-day we have to
know the story of America and if we
don't we won't know what it's like to
try to say
important it is to save America say they
mentioned John Kennedy nobody quoted the
framers and founders more than Ronald
Reagan Democrats what's happened to
those Democrats where are those
Democrats today not many no they're not
there I mean well John Kennedy was a
different kind of Democrat he was a
Republican yeah he was he started at the
time called him an enlightened cold
warrior he was he was essentially a
Republican look how many times you use
the word freedom in his inaugural
address freedom liberty the founders
that's right all good stuff Jane and
Kraig great to see you both thank you
for joining us thank you